hi guys
i hope everybody is ready and
i think we can start um
i hope everybody had a great conference
so far i really enjoyed and i see
oslo it's a great way how they set up
these online conference here
and also a very awesome set of speakers
so i'm michael stipe i'm a microsoft mvp
and i'm one of the authors of the hot
chocolate graphqlibry4.net
today i want to talk to you about
building real-time applications with
graphql and blazer
and if you think about it with blazer
for webassembly
microsoft for the first time in years
gives us a viable option
to build rich spa applications that run
natively in the browser
but we are going to take blazer to the
next level today
by getting rid of getting rid of the
friction
that you have with traditional data
fetching technologies like
rest or grpc and putting the
front-end developer into the driver's
seat
i know a lot of networks still doesn't
know what graphql is
or even has the wrong idea about graphql
graphql is commonly mistaken for a graph
database query language
but it actually has nothing to do with
graph databases
or even with databases graphql
is a query language for your api and a
runtime
to execute those queries
[Music]
so let's dive in and have a look and
explore in five minutes what graphql is
and then head into our actual talk
so graphql is this thing where the
consumer of the api or the front-end
developer
defines what he or she wants oh sorry
that is home office lily can you go out
and close the door
sorry guys my daughter sometimes just
runs in
okay so graphql is this thing where the
front-end developer or the
consumer of the api defines what he or
she wants
so this is done by writing up a graphql
query so the graphql query that you see
here
is basically fetching the current user
and from the current user
just the name and if we send that to our
server
we basically um get our
request filled up with data it's not
exactly like that but it's a good mental
picture to think about that
so we're sending in a request graph and
the
graphql server fills up that graph with
data
but it's not only about flat data or
simple requests like that
we could even decide to change our
request
so we at the consumer could change our
request without changing the server
and for instance asking for the profile
picture
and we don't only want the flat profile
picture we also want some metadata about
the
the profile picture like the width and
the heights
of that picture and if we send that in
to our server we get back a tree of data
so graphical is not only about flat data
structures
it's also about getting trees off data
and if you think about this
it really is more a more human way to
explore data
because you can drill into data and with
that graphql actually gets rid
of common problems like the n plus one
problem on the client side
because if i drill into multiple objects
like for instance i want to fetch the
current user
that is locked into
that is locked into our service and i
want to have from that current user that
is locked into our services name and the
date time when he he or she was last
seen
but i also want to uh drill into that
object and get
the friends of that currently locked in
user
and the name and last scene scene
timestamp
of these users too for instance
this might be useful to build up a list
of online statuses of
my of my friends on a service
and when i send that into this server
the server is
able to then just fetch these data in
one go
and if we think about traditional apis
and even facebook had that problem
back when they invented um graphql
is that with rest the requests
are basically defined or designed ahead
of time
and they don't represent all the use
cases that there might be
so with rest we would probably end up
doing a multiple consecutive calls that
lead to cascading data quality so with
graphql i just can ask the server give
me
the currently logged in user and its
friends
but if we look at the query we already
see some repetitions here
and graphql has a concept that is called
fragments and with fragments actually
i have a primitive for composition and
it allows us to create basically um
a hierarchy for fragments as we create
hierarchies of components in our uis and
that really
closely aligns and we see that later in
the talk in my demo
okay so with graphql we have actually
just one endpoint because
we as the consumer of the api we define
what data we want to fetch so we just
need one endpoint to
issue those requests too and that also
means
that we can fetch everything every data
that we need
in one per specific moment in time
with one request and that
removes the overall under fetching
problem that we
face with other api technologies
and graphql is built on a strong type
system and initially i said it's a query
language for your api
and it is a runtime to enforce those
or execute those queries and graphql
makes sure that you do know
type violation like if you're exposing
on your server side a field that you
that is a string then it's guaranteed
that it will never become
in on the client side and
if you think about technologies like
swagger where you define a schema or the
schemas
inferred from a type system but you
still could
send in invalid data because there's no
enforcement no runtime that enforces a
type system
and this is also useful because uh
nullibility
of the type system like if you're saying
something will never be null
can be um used on the client side
because you can trust that the
server will honor its contract
and that or makes a graphql very
predictable to use
so let's head into um blazer or the
actual
subject that we want to explore with
graphql
and i said initially with blazer
microsoft for the first time
in years gives us a viable option to
build
real rich spa applications that
run natively in the browser and what
does it mean
so microsoft actually built up a mono
runtime
so basically a net runtime and they
build it up on top of webassembly
and web assembly is not a plug-in
technology
and it's no transpilation into something
else like javascript it's real.net
that runs in the browser
and that means we really can run.net
core in the browser and
um that also means that we can use all
the code that we built up in the core
and dotnet standard and it's done
in all these dot nets and now versions
and just
use it in our laser web assembly
webassembly
projects and to
ask me that means we have to use less
javascript
and we can almost do anything with
net and all of this runs
at neo-native performance because it's
not a plug-in technology and it is not
transpiled to
let's say javascript or something like
that
and as i said web assembly is not a
plug-in technology is actually built
into every modern browser so it's a web
standard
and it runs already everywhere
you can run it on your phone you can run
it
on safari on on edge
and all the browsers that are up to date
not internet explorer by the way
okay so um blazer is open source like
the rest of asp.net
and that really makes it
super awesome because we can go to the
repository look how they build that
stuff up we can reason about their code
and also
provide issues or feature requests i
really encourage you to head over to
their um
to their repository and engage
okay so how does blazer work um
actually in order to create laser ui
components we are using combination of
c-sharp syntax and we will see that in
the
demos i have a combination of c-sharp
code and razer syntax and basically that
compiles into a blazer application
and the mono-web webassembly runtime
will be downloaded with our blazer
application into the browser
and enables us to run normal.net
assemblies
right in our browser and when you run a
blazer application
in your browser and you look at the
developers networks tab then you see a
lot of
net dlls that you think is very strange
and some people ask is that safe there's
a dll downloading into my browser
and yes it is because webassembly is
actually
run in a web assembly vm so we have a
sandbox there
so there's no native access to your
computer
and actually these web assembly
applications
uh are not even allowed to update the
dom directly
there is talk about the standard group
to enable that but at the moment the
webassembly
vm cannot update the dom of the browser
so how that is done basically is that
blazer builds up a shadow domain and the
blazer components really modify this
shadow dom
and then there is a javascript router so
you also
see that there is a blazer.js and there
is a mono.js
and basically this javascript router
will
uh batch changes of the shadow domain
very efficiently to our browser domain
the browser and that works also the
other way around
because all the changes on my browser
dom will be patched back to the shadow
dom and then we
get events raised in our net
components and 3d can
work just with dotnet so we actually
don't see this javascript
okay so let's just quickly
discuss the state of blazer because a
commonly asked question
is how mature is blazer so
blazer for the server side and we are
not talking about blazer for the server
side in this talk
blazers for the server side is actually
um
already out with dot net core 3.0 so
it's battle tested
it's uh it's out for over a year now
and um it has proven its gain
and basically what they changed is they
they swapped out
the way they update the browser dom
and introduced laser web assembly and
that shipped just in may so it's
very new um but so far i handled any
issues
but it's very new um
but microsoft really wants to go further
with that
so microsoft wants to enable you to
really take your knowledge that you
acquired in the web with blazer
and put that on the browser so there are
previous upcoming with
net five that
pulled blazer that basically blazer for
progressive web applications and
electron
and then like like with slack you
like slack for instance is also an
electron app gesture you can then build
up applications with blazer that
are real desktop applications but
microsoft is actually going further
and there are investigations or
experiments
with blazer for native and last year at
nec actually steve sanderson showed off
that you can swap out the renderer of
blazer
and put in some other component
technology
for instance he took flutter which
actually is written with that
so not even.net and basically blazer
produced
flatter components uh he called this i
think uh blitter
but there you can see what potential is
there and microsoft is putting a lot of
its x into the blazer baskets so there's
a lot more coming
with blazer but i think that is
enough for an introduction because we
want to build a real-time application
that really takes blazer to the next
level so um i like a lot of code
so let's dive into some code so when i
thought about what could we build
in a talk like that and what is a really
engaging
real-time application i immediately
thought of
something like slack because if you
think about it slack actually
um exposes different kinds of data
fetching capabilities like we initially
when we open the channel or open the
chat we fetch data
simple fetch and then we write messages
that is basically mutating the service
date
and on top of that we have real real
time like the bubbles
uh for instance when there are new
messages coming in or if i'm in a
conversation
really the messages that are coming in
so um slack is really a good example
of a real-time application that really
is engaging with the user so i thought
let's build a
blazer clone it won't be as beautiful as
the actual
as the actual blazer but let's uh try to
build something up let me just uh
smaller okay okay so
let me just open up my first demo
and uh we'll start with something simple
let's uh let me just uh run that
application it's a
it's just a shell so far and um
i walk you through how this application
looks like so we do
need watch run so we can change the code
while we
work on that and it recompiles let me
open chrome and then uh
we'll just open it okay and
what we see here is basically a simple
layout for
a slack clone so on the left-hand side
we
so channels or stuff like that and at
the moment we just have dummies here
and then we have the main pane where we
have all the message
interaction and that is what we built
out later in the demo
so first we want to fetch all the users
that we basically can interact with
so we will fill out this pane so let me
walk you through
the code a bit so if we open up a
laser application like that we basically
can see there is a program cs and the
program cs is very familiar to us
because it's actually
what we have in all these uh all console
applications we have it in asp.net core
applications
so it's very familiar how what that is
and
even in blazer has a main um main method
so that is not nothing new to us
the next thing is we have a host builder
here and that's like in
asp.net core we have some kind of a host
builder that sets up all
our environment the difference here is
that our builder has a root component
and this root component app
if we go in there we can see that it's
not c sharp code it's laser code
and it hosts another component and
this main component is actually where
the magic is happening
the main component has at the moment
just a people list in there
and some area where i can put codes
and in blazer there's a concept of dumb
and smart components or smart and dumb
components or you could say
also stateful components and stateless
components
and main is our state full component so
everything
with date and will happen in our
main razer
okay so then we have our dumb components
or a stateless components
and we basically can
can see the people list here and the
people list
now has some html here so it's not just
a
native laser tags we can put just actual
html in here
and we can see here the placeholders and
if we have a look at the placeholder
they are just html
last but not least and that is the item
we want to basically
now bring to life is the person item and
that represents an actual
person in our list later so let's have a
look how we can bring that
thing to life so um
just as a side note basically how that
works with those
components is that the smart components
will push data down their component tree
and then if these stateless components
will interact in blazer they will throw
events
and the main components can react to
those events
okay so let's bring that thing to life
so we want to fetch data with graphql
here right
so um the first thing uh we need to do
is adding a package
i did that already it's the strawberry
shake package as i said i'm one of the
authors of the hot chocolate graphql
library for.net
the hot chocolate is actually the
backend or the graphql server and
strawberryshake is the
graphql client okay so this is already
set up the project
the one thing i have to do now is to
initialize my project to
run a graphql client and how i'm going
to do that is basically
in visual studio code so in visual
studio for windows
um it's uh more guided
through ui i'm i'm a visual studio code
developer so we do more with consoles
yeah
so i have a cli too tool here that
is from store that comes with the
package strawberry shake
and so i can do dotnetgraph ql
in it and then i have to add
the graphql
url from my server and i
can give my client basically a name i
call it chat
so we have a chat client i initialize it
basically what now happens
is we are downloading a
chat graphql schema and that's the
schema from my server with all the types
and basically the client compiles
against
this schema we will see what that means
in a bit
so the next thing i need to do is
writing up queries so i need another uh
query file so i'm adding a file
queries here the graphql it actually can
be named anything and you can have
multiples so if you have various clients
or various uh
very um files that's not a problem
okay so the next thing we should do is
head over to our graphql ide because our
graphql ide is much better to explore a
graphql endpoint
and this graphql id is called banana
kickpop it's also about
it's also built by our open source
project
okay so i um i prepared already uh
here an empty pane my server is set up
and i already specified a token here
so what i can do now is first have a
look at my
graphql endpoint so let's explore the
schema so i can see there are a lot of
queries here
and i can see there is the me query and
i showed you the initial example of my
graphql where i
basically a query on sme node but i also
have other things like i want to
really query for people and i can see
that my people endpoints actually a
paging api
and it exposes a person here and i then
can drill into the
structure of my uh graphql server here
before i even do the first fetch
um and then i can see a person actually
has
a name and i need a name and also
the last scene date and to have this
online status i want the last scene date
okay so let's oh
i just closed my demo let's do that
and write up some graphql so initially i
actually showed you the shorthand syntax
we are using the longer syntax now
so i'm specifying i want to do a query
here and the query should
fetch persons
okay and and then i want to fetch from
the
people field and actually um i saw
there's a field nodes
i also have intellisensia by the way and
from the nodes i want to have the name
and i want to have
the last c okay i can execute that
i get some data back i can see oh it's
it's actually not sorted like i wanted
so
with hot chocolate you have also the
sorting apis and these filtering apis
it's not a graphql uh in heavy graphql
but some graphql servers have such
capabilities
um so now let's just
order by name
and okay that's exactly what i want so i
can grab this query
and go with it over here paste it into
my
query document recompile it
and what actually now happens is that we
really compile
from the queries so this this query is
actually compiled
let me show you that if
i would like put a mistake in here
build that then actually my um
my the compileprocessof.net would
tell me that uh there is a field people
that does not exist on krabby and that's
true i can
even jump here to my mistake and fix it
so it really compiles
and it compiles into c sharp code so i
now have here a person
that actually has a name and the last
scene so actually what i specified in my
query now manifests as the sharp code
okay so let's build our client up
so let's go to components and start with
the
smallest component and that person item
and i can see that my personal item
wants a username and the user last seen
here
so i said we are pushing data in so we
need
some way to push data in so i'm adding a
property here
and i'm annotating this with parameter
and that makes it a parameter and
enables me to push
data into that property and now i'm just
adding
like with razer always an ad here
and this becomes actually now the
reference to my property here
and uh takes from the user basically the
name
okay so let's build that in so person
item is now done let's do the people
list
and again we need this is a stateless
component we need some way to push data
in
and in this component i want to have an
indicator that
it's still loading because if it's
loading
i actually want to show these little
placeholders so that we have no
empty no empty
no empty pane here let me fix that
okay and then if it's not
loading and if there are data i want to
show something different
so let's add another property
that really represents our data set of
persons so a person connection is
basically my paging data
and then i can really add here an else
so if
it's not loading and there are persons
then i uh will for each of the persons
and add
so many personal items as they are
persons
so that is um quite simple okay
so we basically built up our list now
let's head over to our main component
see how we
really bring that to life i've said
initially that we can use things like
dependency injection and in order to
communicate with our server
we need a client and we can now use
a directive in razer that is called at
inject
and that basically pulls something out
of our dependency injection
and now we'll just use the chat client
that was generated
that client and
then we have a way to communicate with
our
server okay so um
we have to push data in here so
the way that works is over these
parameters
and i actually have the people parameter
here
and the is loading
is empty so we now have to create some
fields here so that we can bind
our component to our component
parameters to that field
so let's just add um
private pool it's loading
it's loading here and we are loading by
default so when the component
initializes we are loading
and the other thing was the person
connection
and let's just add people here
it's nullable component and then we will
bind the whole thing to
people and here we bind this thing to
is loading
for my typing okay so the next thing we
need is to initialize our component and
there are lifetime functions in blazer
so i can basically use this lifetime
functions on initialize
and say let's initialize my component
and the first thing i would do is fetch
data from my com
from my backend so we have a result
that is a weight chat client
dot get person async and that
there you can see that the operation
from our graphql query
actually became a function now on my
client or a method on my client
and i can call that and then i basically
said
say ensure there are no errors on my
results so i know it's everything is
okay graphql actually supports
partial results but we are not dealing
with them um
and the last thing is we say the people
actually is from our result from the
data we know the data is not nigh
because there is no error
and uh we want the people and last but
not least we said
loading is now false and
in order to update my component tree i
now say state has changed
and with that our thing should work
let's head over to net
and okay we see um our client has
already rebuilt
so let's refresh it oh there's still an
arrow
there's still an error because we
haven't
set up the dependency injection let's
quickly do that
go to our program cs and the dependency
ejection is actually configured
through our builder and actually it's
already generated for us
by our by our strawberry shake client so
i just have to say add chat client
and there is a important aspect about
graphql
because graphql actually is transport
agnostic so we have to also define the
transport
so we use an
http and http client
and that is again an api that we use in
the backend
and that we just can use in blazer now
so we say
at http the chat client
and actually we want to configure
the http client here to use
you just do that
base address and then it's a new ui
and the uri has actually
added that already as a snippet here
move that
okay so we have the address
and then we last but not least have to
add some headers
so we have a token authorization
if it's new
authorization here it's a better token
actually i should have the token in here
[Music]
okay okay so that should work a lot
we basically have a set up our http
client factory here
it's restarting it's compiling it's up
let's refresh that okay our component is
there
and okay we have now our sidebar it was
quite easy and it was quite quick to
build it's a bit ugly but we
anti-ugly fire it in the next step okay
so get could have left that open
let's head over to our slides
so we did it we built our first graphql
integration into blazer it was not that
difficult actually
but let's head to the more challenging
stuff so
what we built so far is basically the
left-hand side we built a simple people
list that just fetches data but we could
have done that with
other technologies as well as easy but
now let's build the more challenging
stuff so
now we are building the middle area
where we um build message bubbles
that uh flow in in real time and we
build a footer where we send messages
and interact
and after i have built this demo there
will be a
link i will post a link and you
basically can send me messages into my
debug session so let's see how that
works
okay we have 30 more minutes i hope that
roof
that we get it done by then
okay so the second demo
is basically the full chat client that
really works
so as the first demo we now have already
set up our base our program cs to have
the configuration for the http client
here
and we have our chat line generated and
actually i
changed the query here a bit to
anti-agrify the left
hand sidebar so we now tracking an
online status here
we are tracking a profile picture here
and
we also have the last scene and i also
already put some components in because
building all those components on the fly
would take too long
so we actually
already have a lot of this stuff that we
need in here like we have a message list
now here
that basically um already has all the
code in that we
would need to build up and we have our
chat message bubble here and stuff like
that
what we will concentrate on is really
bringing these to life
and basically we are building out the
main component
and the main component is now set up as
we left it
basically we have an initialize function
that
fetches the initial data here so
what we gonna build now is basically
when we click on the person
we fetch the initial messages for that
person that we are now communicating
with so when we click on the left
sidebar
we gonna fetch some person the next
thing we need to build
is when we click on the send button then
we really have to mutate the server
state so
change some data and send the messages
to um to our backend
okay and the last thing we then have to
build in and
that is then the real-time stuff so the
messages flow in
as uh we are sending in messages so
let's start
so first let's grab the um the
no not the schema let's grab the query
that we at the moment have in here
let's go to our uh graphql id
and let's put it in there let's just
fire it up again okay awesome
that works we just get some persons here
so the next thing
is um really that we built
up fetching uh the messages of a person
that we are chatting with
and we are gonna do that
let me fix one
okay the way we're going to do that is
let's have a look at our schema
we basically know the email address of
the person we are communicating with so
we are
getting a person by its email and then
we can see here is a message
connection again the paging api or the
relay paging api
that allows us to go through our
messages
and we basically then can fetch
the message so we have a direction here
basically is an incoming or outgoing
message
we have a recipient that is a person a
sender that is a person
the send date and the text so
let's uh try to build from that
knowledge
query so we go back in here and we call
this query again messages
okay
and then we basically would
uh look up a person by email and
this field in graphql actually has an
argument so that means i have to pass
something in here to get the person by
email
and graphql actually has the concept of
variables
where i can define okay there's a
variable email
and this variable email is a string and
this means it's not nullable so you
cannot put null
into that operation and then i can
assign to my
uh argument here the
uh email variable and this basically
translates into a method on
on honesty shop that then has an
argument
email where i can put in my data so i'm
really
creating here my interface for my client
okay let's do the next thing the next
thing is we need the
messages that i have with that person
and
from that message from that messages i
need
uh the id i need the direction
i need the recipient and that is a
person we saw so it's an object
and we need a sender again an object
and it's also a person and then we need
to send date
and the text so we pretty much need
everything in that case
so actually we would need
the name and the email and the online
statement status for these
participants but then again i introduced
the concept of fragments
that makes it much more understandable
how a data graph
works and also drives how we
create components for a c-sharp client
so let's build a fragment
that is called participant
and this this fragment we apply on a
person
and that then we grab these fields here
and actually instead of the fields up
here we now use our fragment participant
here
so and now we really can change our
whole graph
actually because we are using the same
fields here so every person is actually
also
it could be also a participant and if we
look at that actually we
could take that out right okay that is
our person
and then we create our own shape for our
client
that is called person and that is now
how a person
is represented in in our c-sharp client
later
and i'll walk you through that in a bit
uh how that generates really
and last but not least we have a thing
that we should call
a message
and that is now our message fragment our
reusable
component here and we put that in
that and now we are just using
components in our functions and
in our um operations and that really
makes
a difference we will see when we can
generate that
but let's first put the last piece in
and that's a mutation so we want to
mutate the server state
and it's called a mutation in graphql so
we say
send message and
and then again we want an email here
because this is basically the email to
which we send or the user to which we
send
our message and then we put in
a text that's a text that we actually
want to send
and it's also a string that cannot be
none awesome
okay and there are quite a lot of
mutations here i could invite friends
but we are picking the send message
mutation
and providing an input here
and we provide the recipient email
it's called email and actually we
provide the text for the message
if you're wondering why there are no
commas in a graphql
they're actually not necessary because
they're the first thing
the compilers of json staff do is
throwing the commas away
so graph the designers of graphical just
uh
just decided they you can put commas in
there but you don't have to
okay so a mutation always returns the
change state of the server so what you
change on the server will be returned in
that case
we are returning the message that the
created object
we also returning the recipient and the
sender because
their state also has changed because
their messages property
also has a new message now in there for
our use case we just
need the message that is produced
because we want the message with all its
ids
and then we just say okay that's
actually also a message
in the way we want it okay let's
grab that
put it over here and let's compile
our um thing right
did i actually
do that okay so so we're compiling that
and what it actually did is it now
updated our client and we now can see
that we have
actually a person
and this person now is also a
participant
so actually what we generated from the
components is actually the real c sharp
clients with all the
inheritance and stuff like that so you
you really are in control how your
client is chain
shaped and that we as i said that puts
the front
end developer in the driver's seat of
uh of how to fetch data and uh
stuff like that okay so we go in the
main back
and what we're gonna do is now we um
basically put in our message list here
and the message list actually gets again
a loading signal so if it's loading and
shows something different then we are
putting a recipient in
and that's the selected recipient and we
have to build that
and then we uh last but not least we are
providing also messages the messages
that we have with that person
so the first thing we are going to do is
let's um
let's add another field here
that is called a person
which is a person and the recipient
recipient and then we
have the second field that we need and
that is an immutable
list which is a
immutable list of messages and we call
it messages
and in the beginning it's just immutable
list
messages empty so it's just an empty
because at the beginning nothing is
selected so it should be empty
okay and now let's really
build up our future so when we click on
a person
the first thing we we basically get
provided the component
really sensors down the the the person
on which
the user clicked so i get an object here
and i
really could then just grab our client
code here so i don't have to type so
much
and change it and say okay actually
we are going to fetch the messages now
so you see the client really generated
these new operations in and i can then
just grab my person
that is already in my component tree
here and just pass in the
email okay i ensure that there are again
no errors
and then i really set my uh fields here
i said the person is now the recipient
and actually the messages
such as is now an immutable list
and create range and we actually
take from the result again we know that
data is not null because we have no
errors
so we take from the person by email
operation we take the messages
and from that the nodes
and this is not known when there is no
error
and last but not least we just inform
our
our api that we have our ui that we have
changed the state and the comments shall
be updated
before we start that let's just put in
the last piece
and that is sending the message and that
is um
also quite simple so when uh on the
message list basically a click sentence
is raised
and this message here is raised and
basically we can just grab
the code that we have here
and then modify it again because
instead of getting the messages we are
sending a message
and instead of person we're using now
our recipient
property and we say okay we know it's
not now when this is raised
uh i will answer to the questions uh
once we are through that demo um
okay and then we just provide the
message that our event sends in here so
the component gives me the message that
is
really produced here and then we uh
really send that
to our server and show again and that
there are no errors
then we update just our messages
messages add
and we now grab from the result because
i said we are reselecting the
uh change state of the server so we're
just grabbing
the message here and we are state has
changed
so we're updating the service date so
this should actually
run let's try it out
it's always a surprise when it doesn't
watch run because we are going to change
it there's no real time
yet and that's the last piece we are
putting in
so let's start that okay it's up
let's just call our client so we can see
and now we have uh the left hand side
pane which actually is now
a bit more anti-uglified we can now
click on it and
now we can see that the server that we
fetched
actually the messages from my server i i
can see by the way that we did a mistake
here it's not ordered
so we add an order in a minute um but
okay we have the messages in here
and i can also send something
and send something we send it
and we have here
so um so we can see that
uh that all works let's get some
real-time data in there
uh let's head back to our graphql id and
build it up
so actually i said we did a mistake here
because it's not what the messages are
not ordered correctly
so uh let's put some order in here
and say uh we are ordering
it by the send date ascending uh yeah
ascending
okay so that fixed our error is the
message sorting we will see that when we
put that back in
and last but not least let's put in um
uh real-time data and real-time data is
reading in graphql is the same thing
then
a query or at least from writing then up
we basically say okay we have
subscription and subscription
real-time operations and the
operation here we call it receive
messages we could also
call it unreceived messages or something
that we want
and then we can have a look at what
operations
or fields do we have here we have one
field and one field in this case is an
event
we have an on message received here
and if we hover over that we can see
that this is a message so we are getting
messages as they receive
as we receive them on the server it's
pushing them down to us
so we can now use our data shape again
our fragment here
and say okay that's a message but
actually
in this case i really want to rename the
field for my client side and call it
message um and that's just an alias so
you can also rename the
fields that the server tells you so it's
nicer with your api
on the client side okay let's
grab that and really just
copy it back to our
code this one
okay okay it's already rebuilding
and let's get back into our main
component
we love that and
put in the real-time data so how that
works is and i'm just
adding that from a snippet here and
explain it because it is a bit of more
code
so really i have a different name here
just let me fix that up and then i
explain it
okay so messages actually
real-time data is represented in our
c-sharp client as uh as something called
a response stream
and response stream is actually an async
innumerable so what i can do is i
can tell my client i want um to receive
the messages
and then i get back async um innumerable
or response stream
and then i can wait for each asyncly for
each
of that as long as it works and each
result i can check is there an error in
that result or
and is a recipient by the way set here
then add that to my
to my message list
so um and i really run that in a task
just with task run so multitasking is
also
quite simple with um with
blazer because i just can't task run
like on the server really it's
net core here it's nothing special like
with silverlight
and um then i'm just
in this case i could do it more
sophisticated but just for the demo
where we just begin receive messages in
our initialize function that will
basically open up the connection to the
server and receive messages as long as
we
uh uh iterating through that but we are
not done that
because real-time data actually doesn't
work over http
we need another transport layer here and
in this case we are using
actually a web sockets and we did a lot
of work to abstract that
and actually the api now works as the
same like the http factory you can put
middlewares in
it's just uh saying uh at websocket
client here
then you specify the client and you
actually just specify the
yuri ui you want to connect to
in this case i'm using a token of
as an as an argument to my um
to my uri but i wouldn't do that in real
life i would use
message based authentication here
and put really the authorization token
on the message
and there are also other stuff that you
have to take care of in real life
example but okay for now we put in
basically just we said at websocket
client here
specified our ui and uh the thing should
have recompiled
and should work now let's refresh and
refresh that
um let's see if that works
yeah that works out better i have a
message here i could write something foo
and now really let me just head over
back to my
slides now you can we
can test that you can grab this your url
and then you can really send me messages
in so um
try to grab that over here
i do that too let's do another window
put that in so chat audience at
azurewebsites.net
we can say uh hello oh there's already
when someone writing in messages you can
see
how they are coming in awesome
you can see how easy it was with graphql
to build real-time applications here
and you still have to do some heavy
lifting like
you have to scale your server correctly
and stuff like that
but um just to get you into graphql and
blazer you can now really build
real-time applications rich sba
applications in the browser
okay so awesome it works it load tests
so let's move on and to our conclusion
testing ndc
okay so we did it
uh i never did this talk actually in 16
minutes and usually i take
one and a half hour because then i would
really walk you
through deeper to this uh through these
examples
uh it's the first time i actually
reached under 50 minutes
there's another conference where i have
to do this in 30 minutes in august
so we'll see how that pans out
okay so my conclusion about these two
technologies here is really do you can
trade much faster with um with blazer
and graphql together
because firstly um i'm actually a
back-end developer
i'm i'm used to c-sharp i'm not good at
javascript
and blazer actually enables me to use
all my
knowledge that i acquired and use all my
apis that i
used for years and really run that in
the browser
and uh soon really run that as an
electron app
and recreate awesome desktop
applications with that so you can re
reuse a lot of code and reuse a lot of
knowledge that you acquired as a c-sharp
developer
and really with graphql you can fetch
data so much more efficiently
and it's not just some untyped data
graphql is really
strongly typed and um awesome to set up
and it really
enables you as a consumer of the api
um and strawberry shake actually is at
the moment
preview we targeted actually to release
it in may
it's a public preview so you can chime
in there
we are now targeting end of jul july and
hope to get it done by then
also the tooling that you saw here we
have like
our project also built this graphql ide
called banana cake pop
and we are also building at the moment
uh integration into visual studio so you
just can click
and add a graphql client to your
um to your solution without any console
tools
and really we bring in a nice syntax
highlighting and
intellisense to visual studio basically
what you sell in
banana cake pop will be integrated into
visual studio
um and we are not stopping there because
i said graphql s3 transport agnostic so
we are also working on the server and
client side to
uh to provide it over grpc so you can
have much smaller payloads
than with json payloads okay
so if you want to head to our project
it's basically go to
chilecream.com or to our github
repository it's all open source
and um i hope you enjoyed the talk and
now i'm
heading to the questions that
let me just see where they are
okay let's start at the
which i could have a whole room for lego
yes uh that is actually my it was my
son's room i made it into an
office uh and it was his lego room i'm
sorry to him so i
have to kick out my kids all the time
and there's still
messages coming in this is so simple wow
the hotshot and strawberry apis are so
easy used yeah and that is
one of our main design goals to make
graphql really simple to donate
developers
um would be nice if there is some magic
to autocall
state has changed uh yes but
i imagine that is quite uh challenging
also but uh i mean it's
it's uh easy and you can control really
when you want to update
the componentry
you can also unmute yourself and ask
questions in person by the way
oh yeah uh there's so there is a
question about often
authorization with um graphql
and that is really baked into um hot
chocolate the server side
so basically you can put authorized
directives on your fields
and then specify a policy and we are
basically using the policy api from
from asp.net core so then we
basically apply these policies on your
data
and we are doing uh much more there with
version 11 we are
planning to bring in a new api that also
does
data trimming so basically that we use
policies to
get data out of the results
there there's no script support
um so what's the name of the tool
so the graphql id is a banana k-pop you
get it
head over to our homepage basically
or our repository and then you can grab
graph the graphql ide there
we are developing actually uh turn off
tools yeah there it is
graph banana kpop names are epic yeah
we thought uh simple names like
graphql.net so
this is boring or in graphql so we uh
we really love how the javascript
community is naming the components so we
started
naming them actually like
cakes or drinks
could you briefly uh how query servers
work
in the server oh there
that's a real whole conference talk
i have about that it's
and there are so many ways you can do uh
resolvers in the back end
and really with hot chocolate you can
also just uh
just do schema stitching
so the the hot chocolate server has
really rich capabilities to merge in
data
and stitch data together from various
data sources
so just head over to our slack channel
it's posted on our repository and then
you can
um just talk to us we have a really
really active
slack channel uh in graphql server
also providing the websocket server yes
so um
basically we have built a middleware uh
for for graphql and all these like um
all these communication protocols are
natively supported by us
so you don't have to code anything you
just say use graphql
or use graphql websockets and stuff like
that and then
it's really in your server and on the
client side you saw these add
websockets that's really generated from
us for you
so all this data handling we do a
connection pooling
and you can really put in middlewares on
top of that and
we really do that for you any more
questions